FEMALE SPEAKER: So thank you all
for coming to this talk.
As you know, we're going to
have D-Rev here today.
And D-Rev is a San Francisco
based design company that
focuses on designing, building,
and selling products
for people living on
less than $4 a day.
Their latest product is the
ReMotion Knee, which is a
prosthetic knee that compares
and performs just as well as
comparable knees but
is 1/5 the price.
So we're going to have D-Rev's
CEO, Krista Donaldson, speak
about this product as well
as the PM, Vin Narayan.
And they're going to have
a short presentation.
Afterward, it will be
open for questions.
So start thinking of what
you want to ask them.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Thanks,
[INAUDIBLE].
OK so I'm going to get
a little bit started.
So just to give you a little
bit of an overview, what I
thought I would do is tell
you a little bit about my
background, and a little bit
about D-Rev, and then about
the knee, the ReMotion Knee,
which is a prosthetic knee for
above knee amputees.
And so you'll see some pictures
with people who've
lost their leg above
their knee.
And then I thought I would share
a few lessons learned
that we've had along the way.
And yeah, and I would
love questions.
So definitely let me know.
And then to introduce my
colleague here, this is Vin.
And he also-- detailed questions
throw at him.
It's good for him.
OK, does anyone know what the
product is in this picture?
AUDIENCE: Tooling.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Tooling.
There is tooling there.
But that's not what
I'm getting at.
I'll give you a hint.
It's mild steel.
And it's Kenya.
I won't make you suffer too
long, but I'm going to make
you suffer a little bit.
AUDIENCE: A pump.
Water pump.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Yes,
a water pump.
So what this is-- what you're
looking at is the Super
MoneyMaker.
And this is actually--
there are several Super
MoneyMaker pumps.
And I know the name sounds
a bit funny by Western
standards, but it was meaningful
to Kenyan farmers.
But what this is is
a treadle pump.
And this one actually works
by tilting your body
weight back and forth.
And it enabled farmers,
small holder farmers--
like two hectares or less-- to
be able to irrigate their
farms, whereas before, they had
been dependent on rain and
just pulling water
out of the river.
I'm showing you this picture,
though, because I worked here
for four years.
And one of the things I learned
is that what you're
seeing here is some of my
colleagues doing inspections
on the manufacturing.
And it was really boring work.
And later on KickStart,
the organization--
they were called [INAUDIBLE] at
the time, decided to move
manufacturing over to
China or most of it.
So keep this in mind.
And I'm going to fold
that back in later.
So here is actually a
picture of the main
Super MoneyMaker pump.
And it works like a stair
stepper machine, pulls water
out of the ground, and pushes it
like another eight meters.
And this picture is actually
from Mali.
My job when I was there
was manufacturing.
And so that's why I was worried
about things like are
people getting bored doing
inspections, because one of
the key things I learned is that
it's not just about how
well you design the product but
how well the product gets
made and how consistently
good the product is
continued to be made.
And this is an artisan at one
of our manufacturers called
Kenya Vehicle Manufacturers.
After I worked in Kenya
for a little
while, I worked in Iraq.
And I was like the super peon
at the State Department.
And what my job was was
basically to put out fires,
literally, between like a lot
of the contractors and the
policymakers.
And for those of you who
followed reconstruction in
Iraq, you may have noticed
that what a lot of the
policymakers were saying from a
technical standpoint didn't
really make sense.
And my portfolio was
electricity.
And so here you see I'm actually
standing in front of
a power plant in Dora, which
is just south of Baghdad.
The big lesson learned there
is the US government only
really thought about trying
to get the power up.
Remember how I said that the
policymakers were focused on
these things that didn't
make sense?
Well, one of them was how many
megawatts can we produce?
I think any of us who remember
high school physics know it's
actually not about megawatts.
It's about megawatt hours.
And what it really is about is
if an Iraqi, at the end of the
day, can flip a switch
on the wall, and
their power comes on.
Right?
The numbers are kind
of meaningless.
But the US government didn't
think about, for example,
where the fuel was going
to come from to
run these power plants.
They were very busy rebuilding
these power plants.
They didn't think about where
the power was going to go from
the power plants in the
transmission lines, which I
have another picture for you.
This is a transmission line
between Baghdad and Dora.
And it's very easy to
bring one down.
This is one of the super
highways of power.
There are only four going
in and out of Baghdad.
And you can strap an explosive
to the leg--
it's sad that I know this--
and you can bring
it down very quickly.
And this would happen during
election season.
So kind of the lesson learned
for me at least was you can't
just think about the thing,
the power plant.
You can't just think
about the tower.
You have to think about
how the whole
system works together.
So that leads a little
bit into D-Rev, the
organization I lead now.
And D-Rev is short for
Design Revolution.
And we are a nonprofit.
And our mission is to
empower poor people.
And when we talk about poor
people, what we really mean is
people living on less than $4
a day, but really about them
empowering themselves.
So getting away from the more
traditional foreign aid model,
which is giving, and high cost,
and not necessarily
higher return in terms of social
impact, but really
looking to where do people
want to empower their own
lives and supporting that.
We focus on two areas.
One of them is improving health
and improving income.
And they're not opposite ends.
Some of the products we work
on, like the knee, are
actually both.
If you can improve someone's
mobility, you're actually
improving their income.
We also focus on products
that scale.
So one of our founders, Paul
Polak, talks about products
that at least reach a million.
And sometimes he says
10 million.
It really depends on his mood.
But what I say is it's about
a lot of people.
We're working on problems that
aren't necessarily at the
village level.
We're working on problems
that ideally are
at the global level.
Three things to know about us.
One is that we design products
that are world class.
And if you know a little bit
about technology in the
so-called developing world,
you know that there's this
history of appropriate
technology, which is kind of
like these rudimentary, low
cost, local materials products
that were supposed
to help people.
What we're saying is no, we're
designing world class
products, products that if
you're a parent, you would use
here with your children.
We don't believe that just
because you're poor, you
deserve products that are
any less quality.
So when we say world class, we
mean products that perform on
par or better than the best
products on the market.
And this picture is actually
from east Delhi.
The picture's me getting some
user feedback on one of our
prototypes with some
doctors there.
The second thing to know
about us is that
we're market driven.
And what that means is that we
leverage the private sector to
manufacture, distribute,
and sell our products.
And so, again, kind of in
contrast to the traditional
foreign aid where things are
donated or someone has to buy
stuff and donate it, if you
think about vaccines, for
example, that's never going
to be market driven.
It doesn't mean that it's not
important, but it's not going
to be economically
sustainable.
We feel very strongly that
the products we work
on are market driven.
And the reason is that it
holds us accountable.
If you don't design a good
product, people aren't
going to buy it.
But if you don't design a good
product and you donate it, you
kind of don't care.
But what we really care about
is social impact.
And we want people to buy it.
And that way, it's economically
sustainable.
The key thing though, of course,
is if you're going to
design something that's market
driven, it does have to be
affordable.
Next thing-- and this
is a picture of Vin.
Let me just go back
for sec, too.
One of the reasons I like
these pictures is on the
left-hand side, this is, I
think, how we often think of
markets in the developing
world.
But this is also a market.
This is a medical device fair
in Dehli, our colleague,
[INAUDIBLE], here on the side.
The third thing about us is
that we're user-obsessed.
I know we all talk about
user-centric design.
We try and take it
a step further.
It's not just about the users,
or the stakeholders, and
everyone in that
customer chain.
It's about what's the context?
How much power is there?
Are there voltage surges?
What's the temperature?
What does the market
look like?
What's the landscape
of other products?
How are people meeting
the need now?
And if they're not meeting
the need, why not?
So the picture here of my
colleague, Vin, in Ecuador
talking to one of our amputees
who's wearing our version two
of the knee.
So what do we do?
So D-Rev is based in
San Francisco.
We like to say that we have
one foot here in Silicon
Valley and one foot in
the places we work.
If you think about the
design process--
I know for those of you who
develop products, this is a
total oversimplification.
And we agree, but identify
is the problem.
Identifying what the problem
is, understanding the
landscape, what's the market
look like, what do the supply
channels look like, how are
things being met now, what are
the challenges?
Design is what we kind of
think about design.
Conceptual design, iterating,
prototyping, moving down the
way to design for
manufacturability and getting
ready for a market-ready
product.
And then delivery for things
that we work on, which is
hardware, is the manufacturing,
the
distribution, getting it
from the manufacturing
door to the end user.
So marketing could
be in there.
If it's medical devices, what
else might be in there?
I am going to pepper you
guys with questions
every once in a while.
Does anyone know with
medical devices?
What else do you need to worry
about besides just like-- if I
want to put a medical device
out there, can I
just go sell it?
AUDIENCE: No.
You need certification.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Yes.
In most places, you do, turns
out not all of them.
But this is something
we worry about.
And, of course, if we're going
to say we're going to develop
a world class product, we want
to have external validation.
It's not good enough,
particularly as a
Western-based organization, to
come in and be like, we've
designed this great product.
How many times have people
heard that before, right?
So we look for external
validation like regulatory
approval or American Academy
of Pediatrics standards.
So that would go in here, too.
And then scaling is I had
mentioned how we're really
looking for problems that
are at a large scale.
So just because something
works in India doesn't
necessarily mean it's going to
work in sub-Saharan Africa, or
Kenya, or East Africa, or even
smaller markets-- and trying
to understand that, and what's
our strategy, moving into
where there's an existing
real need.
And then, because we're a
nonprofit, we want to measure
the impact.
And I'm very passionate about
this measuring, because I feel
like you don't really understand
if you're reaching
your goals if you don't
measure it, right?
So I mentioned we're
a nonprofit.
We say we like to act
like a for profit.
And this has been really
interesting for me as D-Rev
has been growing a little bit
because people kind of stumble
on the nonprofit.
And they think about it like,
oh, you're the charity model.
But no, because we take this
market driven approach, we're
actually a lot like
a for profit.
And it was kind of cool when
one of our first products
launched, people who were buying
it didn't even know
that a nonprofit was behind
the product, which to us,
that's great.
Because we want them to be
buying the product based on
its quality and the value that
it's offering people.
So to give you an idea of how
our funding model works for
something like this, we raise
grants for R&D type money or
for R&D type work
in our design.
And then, as I mentioned, we
leverage the private sector.
So for example, we will license
the design to a
partner who will then
manufacture, sell it, and
distribute it.
So we get income from
our products.
Not very much because at
the end of the day,
our currency is impact.
It's not financial return.
We believe that our partners
should have
some skin in the game.
And just like we want to sell
our products to end users, we
think that we should also sell
our product to partners.
So we have a little bit of
income that comes in that
we'll move around depending
on who our target is.
So for example, if we want
to sell to public rural
hospitals, we might say to our
partner we'll take less
royalties if you sell
more to those types
of clinics and hospitals.
But we do raise a little bit
of grant money to do this
impact assessment.
I would say, particularly now,
because we're a little bit of
a young organization, we're
learning how to do impact
assessment.
And we don't see a lot of
examples of people doing
really great impact assessment
for these types of products.
So we're going through
a bit of a learning
cycle on our own.
OK, so I'm going to start
telling you a little
bit about the knee.
These are three gentleman at
the Jaipur Clinic in India.
And if you're from a place
where you don't have much
money, and you don't have access
to a lot of resources,
and you suffer an amputation,
there aren't a lot
of options for you.
And you can see here,
all three of
them have bamboo staffs.
And that's typical.
People actually won't usually
have a prosthesis at all when
they come into the clinic.
And so they'll be dependent
on this kind of staff.
So just kind of going through a
very quick overview of what
the options could be, this is
a microcontroller knee.
It's called the C-Leg.
And I actually just saw a
gentleman with this last week.
And the minimum you're going to
pay for something like this
is $20,000.
The gentleman I talked to
paid $65,000, I heard.
He and his insurance company
paid for it,
which is way too much.
But this is something like, for
example, US vets coming
back from Iraq or Afghanistan
may be fit with.
It's a smart device.
This is a polycentric knee.
And what that just means is
a four bar mechanism--
I'm going to talk about that
again in a minute-- that more
mimics the natural
walking motion.
The minimum you're going to pay
for something like this is
about $1,400.
So a device that doesn't have
pneumatics, like some fancy
stuff in there, can go $1,400
maybe up to $6,000 or $7,000.
And then this--
and I brought some props.
Thanks, Vin.
This is an international
Red Cross knee.
And it's single axis So you can
see it rotates around the
access like a door hinge.
And this is designed for poor
people, essentially.
And I think, in some ways, this
kind of typifies what you
saw with appropriate technology,
like lower quality
for people who don't
have much.
And what we know is that
in many cases, we hear
anecdotally from prosthetists
we work with, is that people
were in the locked position--
so kind of like a peg leg.
And I'll pass this around if
you want to play with it.
AUDIENCE: Does it have
cushioning at all?
KRISTA DONALDSON: So that would
be attached to a socket.
Yeah, and actually why
don't I just show you
the leg system now?
AUDIENCE: You don't have
the $20,000 one?
KRISTA DONALDSON: I don't.
Sorry.
And if I did, I don't know
if I'd pass it around.
OK, so don't look at the knee
because you want that to be a
surprise later.
But you have a socket.
And then you have an attachment
that goes to a knee.
And then you have a pylon
that goes to a foot.
And this is actually at Jaipur
leg system if you were to go
to the Jaipur Clinic in India
and be fit with something.
AUDIENCE: That's the
[INAUDIBLE], right?
KRISTA DONALDSON: Yes, this
is-- yes, but I don't
want to ruin it.
It's a surprise.
So I'll pass it around,
though.
I won't make you suffer again.
OK, and I want to--
I'm showing you a video
of a man in India.
And he's wearing a single axis
knee similar to-- we actually
have a single axis knee here.
There are hinges on both
sides of his knee.
But it's essentially
a single axis.
And I like this video because
when we think about
prosthetics-- and the medical
device industry thinks about
prosthetics, they're thinking
about here.
They're thinking about generally
flat surfaces, even
stairs, not a lot of dust.
And that's not the reality
of much of the world.
So I'm going to pass
this around.
And in this video you may have
noticed, too, that even though
he has the ability to flex his
knee with a single axis, he's
wearing it in a locked
position.
So you can see that it's
cosmetically awkward.
It's clear he's an amputee.
And it's physically
exhausting.
And particularly with older
patients, you can just imagine
what this would be like.
So the problem that the original
team that looked at
this is for those who suffer
above knee amputations, and
you live on less than
$4 a day, there are
just really no options.
And what's the scale
of the need?
It's about 3 million amputees a
year who need a new knee or
a replacement.
And so you can see the
bulk is in Asia.
And we actually know that about
half a million of those
are in India.
And this is every year.
The second--
the knee that I'm passing around
now is what we call the
version one, the JaipurKnee.
And this was originally
developed by a group of
students at Stanford that
Vin was later a part of.
Oh, sorry.
I'm jumping ahead.
This is the single axis knee.
Back up.
The single axis knee that's
going around--
it's the little one.
Do you see the little one?
OK, hold it up.
Perfect.
OK, this is a door hinge.
This is what the Jaipur Foot
Organization had when they
approached Stanford
several years ago.
And then a student team, which
Vin was later a part of,
developed the JaipurKnee, which
is the version one of
the ReMotion knee.
And you can see there's
a big difference
in the walking motion.
The first knee lacks stability
because as your weight shifts
over that axis, you're going
to lose stability.
And this is a polycentric
knee.
One of the things I like to
mention, too, is with the
design of the JaipurKnee,
which is now
the ReMotion knee--
it allows a lot of behaviors
that are more normal in this
kind of situation.
A lot of people sit
cross legged.
This is a young amputee named,
[? Vishen Barne ?].
You can't see his knee.
But he's fit with one
of our knees.
There's a lot of kneeling for
prayer, squatting, all sorts
of things that a lot of
Western devices aren't
actually really well
designed for.
And we recognize that in
the design process.
So here's the version one
of the JaipurKnee.
Is the leg system around?
I'm going to borrow it back.
Can I borrow it back?
I'll give it back to you.
Thanks.
So what I thought I would do
is walk you through the
iterations of the knee, because
now we're on the V3.
But the first thing is can
anyone tell me what might be
wrong if you're an amputee
and you're wearing this?
AUDIENCE: The noise.
KRISTA DONALDSON:
You're clicking.
And no one wants to click.
And if you think about it, here
there's a stigma attached
to being disabled.
It's that much more in many
of the places we work.
And we saw this with how users
modified their knees.
So here what you see is someone
actually put a bit of
cloth in there to dampen
out the noise.
Another thing we saw is if
you're wearing this under
pants or a skirt,
is it obvious?
Yeah, there's a sharp
edge here.
And it was designed like
this because it
was an early prototype.
It works very well
for what it does.
But the students hadn't
quite worked
through the entire process.
And we see that, too,
with patients.
Wrapping things around the knee
is very common so that
it's not quite so obvious when
you're sitting down that
there's a prosthetic under
your skirt or pants.
So that led to the Q2 knee,
which I'll give back this one.
Thanks.
Thanks, Vin.
So a couple differences when you
pass this around you may
notice that there's a--
anyone know what
this rubber is?
Noise dampener.
This is a little loose, but I
promise it doesn't click.
So there's a noise dampener
right here.
Also you may notice that the
curvature is much smoother to
make it not quite so obvious.
The other thing you may notice,
too-- actually, you
probably won't notice--
is the attachment.
We changed the attachment.
On this one over here, we used
an attachment that was
specific to the Jaipur
Foot Organization.
It was actually threaded.
And that's not ideal for
alignment and for fitting.
So we changed it to a more
universal adaptor, so it would
be applicable to a broader
range of clinics.
And now we're on the version
three, which we just launched
last month.
And if you're holding-- most
of you haven't held the V2
yet, but you'll notice it's
a little bit heavier.
It's a little bit wider.
And in fact, some of the
feedback Vin got in China was
like, this may be fine for you
Westerners, but it's a little
bit big for us, meaning
Westerners are a little bit
more overweight.
So the other thing that we were
very cognizant of too is
if you want to have a truly
affordable product at a high
quality, it needs to be
mass produced, right?
This is CNC, Computer Numerical
Control, cut out
with a mill over
and over again.
Not the most affordable.
Not the best use of resources.
What is this?
Injection molded mostly.
Yeah, so you'll see when
you pass it around,
it's also much narrower.
I think we calculated
26% narrower.
And you'll see it's
much lighter.
And then what we think it's
going to cost-- $80.
So this knee actually is going
to field trials now, which I'm
going to talk a little bit
about in a minute.
But we are hoping for it to hit
the market early next year
at a retail price of $80.
So not a cost of goods or
a bill of materials
but a retail cost.
AUDIENCE: And that's
just for the--
KRISTA DONALDSON: Sorry, no.
That's OK.
AUDIENCE: What was
the material?
KRISTA DONALDSON:
Material is--
VIN NARAYAN: Polycarbonate.
KRISTA DONALDSON:
Polycarbonate.
AUDIENCE: Is that just
for the knee itself?
What about the extension
and the foot?
KRISTA DONALDSON: Yeah,
that's separate.
So the knee itself
would be $80.
VIN NARAYAN: They're all
designed and sold modularly.
So usually people are buying one
component from one place,
another component.
And then the way that they're
connected is standardized so
you can match up products from
different manufacturers.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is the knee the
same for a child?
KRISTA DONALDSON:
Great question.
So I'm going to repeat the
questions for our audience
that's not here.
The question is is the
knee the same for an
adult versus a child?
It's based on weight.
So depending on how large
the child is, they
can wear our knee.
But actually, one of the things
we're interested in is
redesigning the knee at another
point for children,
too, or having a second knee.
That's a great question.
Any others before we move on?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Does the $80 cover
the marginal cost of
manufacturing and
distribution?
KRISTA DONALDSON: Yes.
Yeah and actually we're hoping
we can get it lower.
I think one of the critical
things in this field is people
get really excited
about a product.
And they put out a price based
on how much they think it's
going to cost to make it.
And once they figure out
distribution costs, and
tariffs, and fees--
mystery fees, and all sorts of
things getting them into
countries--
the price goes up a lot.
And from my standpoint, one of
the things I really learned
working in Kenya, is consumer
trust is so critical.
And if you put out a price that
something's going to be
$80, but you come back and you
say, no, actually it's going
to be $200, you've already
had one level of
trust that you've lost.
So we built in margins
based on the best
research we could do.
And then we put a little extra
in for what we don't know,
which we think will
be something.
AUDIENCE: Were there any trade
offs in terms of the product
lifetime, like life span in
terms of the reduction in
costs and whether or not that
means that they would have to
replace it sooner or if it's
comparable to what the
previous ones were?
KRISTA DONALDSON: Well,
there are standards
that we have to meet.
And I'll let Vin give you
the detailed answer.
But essentially, there are
standards that say what the
lifetime of a product must be.
VIN NARAYAN: Yeah, so we hit the
exact same lifetime that
Western devices do.
In fact, I think we go a little
bit further, because to
hit that life that they state,
they also say you can't get it
wet, you can't use it in dirty
conditions, you have to
service it every six months,
which isn't really a reality
for the context we're
working in.
And so we're designing it to
hit that same lifetime but
without any of those
requirements on top.
KRISTA DONALDSON: One of the
things we learned is
obviously, like Vin said, the
testing is kind of based on
Western wear.
And one of the things we really
had to think about
during the product
specifications is well,
actually what is our user
going to be faced with?
And we know there's a huge rural
population that would be
using our knee.
They're going to be in fields.
It's going to be wet.
It's going to be dusty like you
saw with the gentleman,
the rough terrain.
And so how do we make sure that
when we do the mechanical
testing here we account
for that?
Because we don't want to be
discovering that when it's on
our test users, right?
So these are all things that
we're trying to stay ahead of.
So this is Kamal, the young
man earlier who you saw
working on our knee.
And he actually climbed
a tree later.
So we love this picture
of him.
So I had mentioned earlier how
you have to measure to know if
you're hitting impact.
And so with all of our projects,
we're very clear
about what the goals are.
And with this project it's
to re-mobilize people,
re-mobilize above
knee amputees.
And we have usually two to three
meta indicators we use
with all of our projects.
So for the knee project we look
at number of amputees
fit, which is a little
bit of an output.
For example, just how many knees
are there being worn?
And then just to kind of give
you a little bit of color is
that this knee is now in
12 different countries.
We have a knee in 12 different
countries, mostly the V1 knee.
But I think the really
meaningful impact number is
compliance.
And compliance means is the
amputee still wearing the knee
six months later, because that
more tells you are you really
truly re-mobilizing people, with
the goal being increased
income, increased access,
increased
participation in life.
And our compliance rate is about
79%, which is great.
It's not good enough,
we don't think.
But as a sense of perspective,
the ICRC knee
system is about 65%.
And we have learned
through getting
feedback on the product--
and who's got-- where's
the leg system?
VIN NARAYAN: Actually,
the version--
the previous JaipurKnee.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Oh,
the previous?
Sorry, OK.
So also single axis.
So thank you.
Has anyone got the leg system?
It's right here.
One of the things that we've
actually found is that
compliance, one of the things
that hurts us, when you talk
to amputees and you say, what
would you change about it,
usually the first thing
they would say
is, I'm not an amputee.
I'm not an amputee.
But the second thing they would
say is the socket gives
a lot of problems.
So when you see this compliance
number, it's
actually are you still wearing
your leg system.
What's been interesting for us
if you think back that our
goal is re-mobilizing people,
it's made us think about what
could be our potential
next projects.
So it's not just
about the knee.
We know that the socket has a
lot of issues, too, because
people's residual limb
changes over time.
It changes just based on
a variety of things.
And blistering is
a real issue.
I'll give this back to you.
Thanks.
So besides the numbers, I
thought I would share a few
patient stories.
And this is a young woman
named Pernima.
And she lost her leg
in a car accident.
It was actually fairly tragic.
And she lost her
little brother.
One of the things that's really
amazing about her, to
me, I think as a female engineer
particularly, is that
when she was re-mobilized with
one of our knees, she said to
us, I want to go back to school,
and I want to become
an engineer.
And I love that story, because
at the end of the day, we
don't necessarily want people
like us and people based in
the West working on projects
to solve the problems but
people like Pernima addressing
some of the
issues she sees locally.
This is also another
funny story.
So Andreas on the left is
wearing our version two knee.
The version two is actually only
fit on five amputees down
in Ecuador because we were
testing the noise dampener and
things like that before moving
on to wanting to
injection mold it.
But Andreas had lost his leg
in a motorcycle accident.
And I'm laughing because one
of the things he was most
excited about being re-mobilized
was to get back
on the motorcycle.
So here you see him here quite
happy to have his new knee
with his friend.
So to give you a sense of where
we are now with the
knee, this is--
I had mentioned the
12 countries--
and hopefully these
dots add up to 12.
But this is where our knee is
in use right now through our
partnership with the
Jaipur Foot Clinic.
So they actually have a central
clinic in Jaipur, India.
They have 22 other clinics
around India, Delhi--
basically name your major city,
and they have a smaller
clinic there.
But they also do camps
in other places.
And so they fit the version
one knee in all
of these other countries.
As I mentioned, we're just
starting our version three
field trials.
And we're doing that in five
different countries.
As of last week, Vin just
returned from Indonesia, two
clinics in Indonesia that
are trying out our
version three knee.
And here's a picture, actually,
of the first amputee
fit in Bali.
And we love his smile.
And actually this is our
colleague, Sam, behind him
checking out alignment.
And what we're really looking
for in these field trials is
does it work essentially, do we
see an increase in income,
increase in quality of life, but
also are there any things
that we need to know before we
really scale up into mass
production.
Are there any feature tweaks,
or anything that
we need to be changing?
And so we have a six month study
running at each of these
sites where we're getting
feedback on
all of these things.
So one of the things I'd like
to mention too, even though
this project, we haven't done
a lot of PR about it--
Stanford did in the early days
with the version one, but
we've gotten inquiries from all
of these different places.
And what's been really
interesting to me is that
we've also gotten inquiries
from the US, patients who
either don't have insurance or
people, for example, who have
a very active lifestyle, often
vets, who come back.
And they don't want to be using
that $20,000 knee to go
to the beach or to
go kayaking.
So I think a take away for
us is that there's a need
globally, not just in our target
populations where they
live on less than $4 a day.
So I thought I would share a few
lessons learned, because I
don't want you to think
that we have
everything figured out.
We're far from that.
And just to tell you what this
is because you saw this
earlier, these are some of the
early sketches that went into
the design of the V3.
We feel very strongly that
people should be proud of
their prosthetic.
And at least, it should fit
with them in their life.
So we worked with a volunteer
industrial designer who did
these renderings that led
to the V3 design.
So this is a picture of a
prosthetics clinic in Kenya
that I went to go
visit last year.
And actually I was there for
one of our other projects.
But I wanted to find out about
this clinic and how
it worked in Kenya.
Couldn't get them to
answer the phone,
which is not unusual.
So we just dropped in.
And four skilled processes,
which is not necessarily
unusual, but it's pretty cool.
One of the big challenges we
see with getting people
re-mobilized is they might
have-- for example, in Haiti
they might have a lot of
donated technology.
But they don't have the skilled
processes to fit people.
But these processes, four
processors, were really busy
not doing much of anything.
And the reason was because they
could not get all the
components to that leg
system that we talked
about into the clinic.
So they were waiting on
components to come in.
And in the meantime, even though
they had amputees that
needed to be fit, they weren't
actually fitting people.
So a lesson learned-- well
actually re-learned, because I
mentioned this came up with one
of my lessons learned in
Kenya-- is impact is more
than the product.
It's about getting the product
to people and getting the
product to people who need it.
And going back to our model of
market driven, one of the
reasons why we're market driven
is because if people
see value in your product,
they're going to buy it.
And if they see value in
your product, they're
going to use it.
But you have to get
it to them.
So another kind of reminder take
away is really truly if
your focus is impact, you've got
to think much beyond the
product or the thing
itself and think
about that whole system.
The next thing we've
really learned is
good design is global.
And my hope is that
the foreign aid
community has seen this.
Because we still get a lot of
questions of like, well, why
are you based in
Silicon Valley?
And I'm like the best products
in the world
take a global approach.
And what you're looking at here
is the design process and
effort by our various partners
and us that we've put into the
design process.
And these little lines actually
do correspond to like
minute design activities.
But if you look at it, Stanford
did a lot of the
early work, if you remember
the student group, and the
Jaipur Foot Organization.
These are color coded if
you can read below.
And then we took over from
the student group, or
they merged into us.
But as you can see, there are
lots of different players.
We have Northwestern
did a little bit.
We have partner clinics who
have contributed a lot.
We've had industry experts who
And my point with this is
it's not just about one
organization.
One organization
can't do this.
It's about a partnership of
ideally the best organizations
in the space.
And so we have partners
in India.
We now have partners
in Indonesia.
We have partners all
over the world.
Manufacturing might
be in China.
But bringing together what we
think is the best for the end
user for us to meet our goals.
OK, and then the last thing is
we think this model scales,
like what we're doing at D-Rev.
And I alluded to one of
the other projects
were working on.
This is Brilliance.
It's a photo therapy device.
It's this thing right here,
the blue light.
And it treats babies with
severe jaundice.
And we don't think much
about jaundice here
in the United States.
But it's actually a big problem
in many parts of the
developing world, particularly
there are certain areas where
people have a genetic marker
that makes them more
susceptible to jaundice.
And if you don't treat jaundice,
babies can suffer
brain damage from very
minor to very
severe, or they can die.
And it's also hard to collect
data about it.
So the medical community is now
trying to deal with it.
But at the same time, there's
not a lot of good data.
And we started this project,
like the knee project, when a
user comes to us, in
this case, and
says, this is a problem.
I'm just going to really
quickly mention
where we are with that.
So Brilliance actually hit the
market through our Indian
partner, Phoenix, in November.
And we're at impact now--
I mentioned that we have
these meta indicators--
number of babies treated-- and
this is for 105 devices that
are now installed
in hospitals--
over 2,000 babies treated.
Number two is what we call
babies otherwise.
And this is counting babies who
otherwise would not have
received effective treatment
if there had been no
Brilliance.
And then last is that we're able
to determine the number
of deaths and disabilities
averted by our product.
And Brilliance retails for about
$400 compared to other
photo therapy devices that are
usually $3,000 and up, ones
that meet American Academy
of Pediatrics standards.
And because you're Google, I
had to put in our favorite
Google Fusion map.
So one of the things we've been
trying to do is track
where the devices are and where
they've been installed.
And so just in the last seven
months, you can see that
mostly India--
one of the things we're really
excited about is that a public
tender was filled.
And that's when the government
purchases devices, which we're
really excited about, because
we know that those get put
into public hospitals.
And public hospitals, we know,
is where the greatest need for
these photo therapy
devices are.
We've seen devices get sold
into the Philippines.
We've seen them get sold to
Uganda, Nigeria, and now
Ghana, which, for me, is really
exciting after you have
this long design process
from the early days to
commercialization.
So I wanted to mention a few
reasons why we're particularly
thankful to Google, too.
The first one is that working
with Googlers and Zooglers, we
won the Hack for Good Hackathon
a few months ago.
And here you can see our team,
Nicole over here with Zooglers
and Googlers.
So thank you.
The other thing is that
we're part of a pilot
that Google is doing.
Has anyone heard of One Today?
Awesome.
OK, so we're part of that.
My understanding is it's
still in beta.
So look for it please and
download the app.
But it's a micro giving.
So you can give $1 or 2
to an organization.
And we're one of the pilot
organizations.
And then we also recently won a
Google alumni impact award.
So Google has been
very good to us.
So thank you for that.
And the last thing
what I thought I
would do is end with--
you're getting a
sneak preview.
Actually this is really
exciting.
So we had a volunteer filmmaker
who works with
extreme affordability
class at Stanford.
I don't know if you're
familiar with that.
But some of our board
members are the
professors for that class.
But he said, I'm
going to India.
Can I film some things
for you?
And we said, we would love you
to capture a patient story.
And so he captured the story of
Dinesh who's 12-years-old.
You'd asked about children.
And this is the Jaipur Foot
Organization in Delhi.
DINESH:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
MALE SPEAKER:
DINESH:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
KRISTA DONALDSON: So one of
the reasons why we're also
really excited about this
is because I think as a
technology organization with a
lot of engineers, we've had a
hard time storytelling and
learning to story tell.
So stories like Dinesh--
we work with our amputees.
And we're out talking
to people.
But it's amazing to have someone
help us tell the story
of the work we're doing.
So I get teared up every
time I see this.
So don't mind me.
So the last thing I want
to show you is--
invite you actually.
D-Rev a couple times a year has
what we call Open Studios.
And what that is is we
just open our doors.
We get a lot of requests for
tours, and meetings, and
things like that.
And we love actually having the
community come in and ask
us questions if they're
interested.
We can show you prototypes.
You can grab a drink.
Anyway, the next one is
going to be July 17.
So we'd love to have you.
If you're in San Francisco,
we're up in the Dogpatch
neighborhood if you're familiar
with the city.
Just Google it.
You'll be fine.
Last thing is thank you.
So thank you for coming today.
And I'd love your questions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Yeah, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: All right.
I notice that your focus
is sustainability.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Economic
sustainability.
AUDIENCE: Economic
sustainability, scalability,
and then as well as solving
a global purpose.
I notice that you're in
a lot of countries.
What's the percentage of
the countries that are
donating to the cause?
And then, it's a compounded
question.
And then you'll also note that
the cost of getting and
importing the goods into
the countries can
sometimes vary, right?
And that's often dealt with--
KRISTA DONALDSON: And the
regulatory totally varies,
too, and the registration.
All of that varies.
AUDIENCE: So are there
discussions, is it possible to
have the countries' state
departments, sorry, instead of
donating necessarily funds or in
addition to donating funds,
relax importation requirements,
and duties, and
fees that way?
KRISTA DONALDSON: That would
be so forward thinking of
governments.
AUDIENCE: Because it's
mobilizing their economy,
mobilizing their--
KRISTA DONALDSON: Yeah.
Let me tell you a
few anecdotes.
You're touching on like 10
really great points in the
things you're saying.
So we're actually going through
a bit of a scaling
strategy with Brilliance, the
photo therapy device that you
saw now, and that partly--
there's such high need.
And we're trying to obviously
match that up with demand.
And what we've learned, for
example, if you look at South
America, like there are some
countries that the economic
conditions are just such that
there's no way a foreign
entity, non-profit or not,
is going to address.
There's another South American
country I won't mention that
there is one of the biggest
makers of photo therapy
devices in the world.
And 90% of hospitals do not
have a functional photo
therapy device.
And that's because that company
is unwilling to bring
the cost down to what
the local hospitals
can afford to pay.
So we're going from corruption,
all the way to
bureaucracy, to all
sorts of things.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So then that leads
me into my other question I
had, which was regarding
managing your supply base.
So you obviously have figured
out that you want to make an
inherent interest in your supply
base to bring the cost
down, so they can
sell more goods.
Do you guys manage the forward
and reverse logistics, or is
that outsourced to
your supply base?
KRISTA DONALDSON: It depends.
And I want to go back to your
question, too, about are local
groups donating.
And Vin can talk more
about this, but
with prosthetics clinics--
it's actually a bit-- we
sell to the clinics.
And when we're doing the field
trials, one of the things I
didn't mention is we have to
understand our end users.
We also have to understand our
paying customer, which is the
clinic itself.
Those clinics raise money
locally usually.
Some clinics will charge
fees or sliding fees.
So we do see local
money coming in
to address the problem.
I don't know.
Do you want to add more
onto that, too?
But then just to answer your
second question really quickly
is it depends on the product.
With Brilliance, we partnered
with Phoenix Medical Systems,
the biggest maker of neonatal
equipment in India.
With the knee, we're going to
manage more of that supply
chain because of some of the
challenges we saw and that
there aren't major players
already in the
space who can do it.
I'm going to hand
it over to Vin.
VIN NARAYAN: Yeah, I think
that's just a somewhat--
I don't know if it's unique.
But it's something that we are
very proud of at D-Rev, that
when we do the design process,
it's not limited to just the
engineering or technology
aspects.
We're also looking at what does
the distribution market
look like for that product.
And it can change from
device to device.
We have a different distribution
model for the
knee than we do for
Brilliance.
And that's all based on what's
available and what we think
the best path to scaling is.
KRISTA DONALDSON: And
best path to impact.
And I would say that the
philosophy and the core tenets
stay the same.
It needs to be market driven.
But the path there we're really
doing based on what we
think is doable but also what's
best for the end user.
And the other thing I would add
is if you remember that
nice neat arrow of the
design process.
And we also know there's
a lot of iteration.
That's much messier.
But in that early stage of
identification, we're really
trying to understand all
of those things.
And we're-- in some ways to back
up what Vin was saying is
we're designing the delivery
model in addition to the
product and very much using
a design process
for that whole system.
AUDIENCE: I just had a question,
because I really
admire the kind of structure
you have that's very
sustainable.
And I think inherent in that
structure is a focus on the
end user, which I really like.
So my question is are there
other companies or nonprofits
that you kind of modeled
this after?
And were there any lesson
learns in the overall
structure that you guys chose
for your nonprofit?
KRISTA DONALDSON: I'll try and
answer that delicately.
I feel like a lot of the model
and the approach that D-Rev
takes is recognition of where,
in many ways, the aid sector
has failed people.
And I hate to say that, because
I don't want to put
everyone in a basket.
Because there's a lot
of great work
that's obviously happening.
But a lot of these things-- like
I saw in Kenya, and Iraq,
and some of the other
places I worked.
And I know Vin has a lot of
experience in working with
prosthetics clinics.
And really, I feel like if we're
not designing for the
end user and for the impact,
then what are we doing?
So everything, I feel like, when
we're making decisions,
it all comes back to what's
best for impact and what's
best for the end user.
And I'll also say one of the
challenges we've had is, like
I had mentioned earlier, is
getting our impact assessment
up and running.
Because the impact assessment
kind of traditional model is
focused, for example, in health
on DLAYs, Disability
Life Adjusted Years, which is
kind of meaningless to end
users and doctors.
It's a very global
health thing.
And we feel like if we're
focused on end users, we need
to really understand what
their needs are, and
understanding if they're using
the product, and how many
babies are using it.
And one of the things--
I wanted to keep the focus
on the knee today.
But Brilliance, we can actually
track the number of
babies that are being treated by
the device, which helps us
with impact assessment.
And so we're always trying to
figure out how to do things
very efficiently, because we
don't fit into the mold of a
traditional product nonprofit.
So if you see other groups--
I mean there's a lot of great
groups out there.
But if you see other groups,
too, we're all ears, because I
feel like we've definitely
struggled through a lot of
lessons learned,
as you can see.
And we're changing our path.
But as much as possible, we try
and learn from what other
groups have been through.
VIN NARAYAN: I think it's also
important to note that the
approach depends on what
products you're working on.
It's not a one fit approach,
as Krista
mentioned, for every nonprofit.
So just like we had to pick the
approach that we think is
most likely to lead to impact,
we also have to pick products
and projects that best
fit our approach.
We'll never do a vaccine
product.
That's not going to happen.
And that's not to say
that this is the
right way to do vaccines.
But we pick products that work
well with our approach and
that we think can scale
easily that way.
KRISTA DONALDSON: I would also
add that we're very pragmatic
at the end of the day.
We're 10 people.
So we're very clear about what
we can and what we can't do.
With jaundice, the biggest need
is actually screening.
But that takes a huge
capital investment.
It would take probably about
five more staff.
So we can't do that until we're
at a different stage.
We also felt like it didn't make
sense to have screening
before there's treatment
in place.
So I think one of the things
that I feel like is one of our
core strengths is that we have
the ability to say, no, we
actually can't do this.
It's beyond our scope, our skill
set, our everything.
And this is best for another
organization.
Now that we have a little bit
more impact, we have groups
coming to us.
And we try and match them with
groups that can carry the
projects forward.
AUDIENCE: That was a good
segue for my question.
First of all, I think
you guys are doing
really spectacular work.
And this has been really
awesome to just
hear from you live.
My question was actually about
impact evaluation.
So you mentioned that you're
kind of setting up how you're
going to be evaluating
impact going forward.
So I just wanted to get your
thoughts on where you're
focusing on for Brilliance or
some of the other products
that you're working with.
And I know there are a couple
of nonprofits that focus
solely on providing impact
evaluation expertise to other
non-profits.
So is that a direction
you're looking for?
KRISTA DONALDSON: We looked
at that, yeah.
So how about I give
the meta answer.
And then I'd love Vin to talk
about the trials a little bit,
because we've done, what I think
is, an incredible job of
setting up data collection
with the field trials.
So on the meta levels, we've
tried to work with some of the
very well known impact
assessment groups.
But one of the challenges we've
run into is that we're
very impact focused.
And a lot of those
groups are led by
academics who need to publish.
And there's not necessarily an
overlap in those two things.
So we've said, can you please
take our project?
We need third party
evaluation.
We would actually love third
party evaluation and for you
to teach us what you're
doing so that we can
do it in the future.
and we haven't been
successful so far.
And that's something that I
actually know a board member
on one of those.
And I've been bugging
him about it.
I think again we try and keep
things very pragmatic.
But I would love you to talk
about maybe the knee.
VIN NARAYAN: So I think one of
the challenges when we were--
so we just set up this
100 unit trial.
And it's going to be running for
the next six months or so.
And one of the challenges with
looking for an outside impact
group was that we needed such
a specific set of evaluation
that I think it was going to
be difficult to set that up
for such a short
period of time.
So what we did was really look
at what we think were the best
practices that some other groups
were doing and try to
implement that in
our approach.
So for example, we looked at
well established prosthetics
evaluation metrics, and gait
metrics, and tried to take
questions from existing studies
that could be vetted
and incorporate that into ours,
and then sort of combine
that with other things that
maybe aren't part of the
traditional prosthetics study
like what is the change in
income six months later, or
things about socioeconomic
status, and how those are
changing, as well as talking
to some other nonprofit groups,
and looking at the
impact work that they're
doing, and how
they're doing it.
A good example is that we met
with one really amazing group
in New York that uses Dropbox
actually to sync.
KRISTA DONALDSON: It's the
little details that make all
the difference.
VIN NARAYAN: And it was like
such a why didn't we think of
that kind of moment.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Because
we were having
them fill out forms.
And we're like no, they can
just load it into Dropbox.
And then it magically appears.
VIN NARAYAN: Yeah, like
let Dropbox do the
hard part of it.
AUDIENCE: Or Docs.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Yeah,
we'll move to that.
Much better--
Docs.
VIN NARAYAN: Stage two.
KRISTA DONALDSON:
That's right.
We're getting better
and better.
VIN NARAYAN: But little things
like that and just kind of see
what people were doing and
incorporating the best
practices and making it fit our
approach really well was,
I think, a really good
lesson learned.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Yeah, the
other thing I would add is
thanks to the SEED program
at Stanford.
I'm not sure if you're familiar
with this big grant
that the business school got
at Stanford to support
enterprise creation in
low income economies.
But we managed to finagle a
fellow named Sara Tollefson.
And she's our official
director of impact.
And I felt very strongly that
impact needs to be managed by
somebody who works on all
of the different teams.
And Sara's got a really
interesting background.
In fact, she's not a traditional
impact person.
She's a lawyer who worked on
Truth and Reconciliation in
West Africa and a few other
interesting things.
But she's very detail oriented,
which I think is the
primary job requirement.
So she works with Vin
and other people.
And we're trying to do some
interesting things to like to
get the data off the Brilliance
machines, for
example-- like the number of
hours it's been used--
we are now working with Medic
Mobile to do SMSes to doctors
and get the data back.
We're trying to combine
with site visits.
We're also running a few tests
and collecting data, like
incentivizing with SMS, calling
ahead of time, and
then kind of comparing all
these different models to
figure out what's the most
efficient way to do that that
is least intrusive
to our users.
So we have a lot of things.
And I think we're a little
bit like you guys.
We like to try a lot of things,
and collect data, and
then go forward from that.
AUDIENCE: So I noticed that
your organization really
pushes using the market to
make great products.
And I'm just wondering if
there's any collaboration with
existing organizations like the
Red Cross that have tried
to build a design that
isn't that great.
And they have massive
resources,
like a lot of people.
They probably have distribution
channels that you
don't have access to.
So I was wondering if there's
any collaboration between
D-Rev and larger nonprofits in
addition to the hospitals and
other partners that you're
working with.
VIN NARAYAN: I think the easy
answer for that is just that
we're always open to
new partnerships.
And for a group like that that
had the distribution channels
in place, that would be a great
partner to work with.
And so we're always open
to things like that.
We're not working with
them right now.
KRISTA DONALDSON:
We're trying.
To answer your question
very directly is yes.
We try and work with the best
people in the field, the best
people with the best
distribution channels.
I'll be honest.
I feel like until recently they
were just like, oh, it's
another student group.
And we're like, we're
not students.
We're actually developing
stuff, and
they're getting used.
So I feel like we're just
building credibility now.
But yeah, I mean every time I
see certain leaders of other
organizations that I know are
donating or buying devices,
I'm like hey, have you
seen the knee?
Or are you interested in
buying Brilliance?
And we're just starting
to get traction now.
So totally yes.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned earlier
that when you're
identifying projects you try
to fit it to your approach.
I just wanted to hear more about
what other factors you
consider when thinking
about new projects.
Do you kind of have people
approach you, or do you do
kind of base from
need finding.
How does that look like?
KRISTA DONALDSON: A
bit of everything.
So we have a lot of new needs
that come into us.
People approach us.
The Brilliance project started
with a doctor coming.
The knee started with the Jaipur
Foot Organization going
to Stanford.
Because we're in so many
hospitals and clinics, we see
a lot of things.
And we talk to doctors, and
we learn about new things.
It's been really interesting.
With people coming to us with
needs, often if they're
Westerners, they're coming
to us with solutions.
They're not actually coming
to us with needs.
So they'll come and say,
oh, this thing is
going to solve x.
And I'm like, well, what's
the problem?
And what's also really
interesting is if you dig into
the problem, it's often
not a problem.
And so we do a lot of due
diligence, too, to really
understand the problem.
And one of my favorite
professors at Stanford used to
always try and get your problem
statement to the next level.
Like if you say, oh,
I need light.
Well, what do you need
the light for?
Like what's the problem you're
trying to solve?
Is it children need to do
homework after dark, or they
want to keep their business
open after dark on a road?
What's the problem you're
trying to solve?
And if you can get there, that's
a good place to start.
We have a framework that we
kind of run needs through.
And it's everything pragmatic
from is this our sweet spot,
are their key opinion leaders
who think this is an issue,
will the key opinion
leaders advise us.
Because as you can imagine,
getting in the door with the
largest maker of neonatal
equipment in India, we just
can't walk up and say hi.
So are there a lot of these
conditions met that we think
that we have a high success
rate of moving forward.
And so that identify phase that
I showed you with the
arrow, it's more than just
kind of like need
identification, talking
to a few customers.
It's a very intensive due
diligence process, which has
been really interesting,
because, for example, funders
aren't interested in throwing
money at you to just go
research stuff.
You have to go research that on
your own and then come back
and say, OK, this is a real
problem that we feel very
strongly about.
And there are these users who
say this is an issue.
And this is the scale up plan
or the development plan.
VIN NARAYAN: And I can tell you
a little bit about what
that conversation went with
the knee, because when it
started, the student team just
had to worry mostly about the
technology because there was
already a partner to scale it.
But when we were deciding
whether or not we should take
it forward as an independent
project and try to scale it, I
think the questions really are--
and these are the same
questions that D-Rev asks--
can we develop it, or is there
a need for the type of things
that we think we're
really good at?
And are their partners available
for the other areas,
is that a ripe space, are there
enough people doing the
other aspects of it?
So questions for us were OK, if
we make a device, are there
clinics that can fit it?
Are there distributors that
will be able to sell it?
How much regulatory work or
other upfront costs will we
need to get into it?
And at the end of all that, will
it still be affordable
enough for the people that
it needs to get to?
And if the answers are yes, I
think that is a really ripe
area for D-Rev to explore.
KRISTA DONALDSON: We're really
looking at where there's a
huge social need and an unmet
market that we think we can
design for affordably.
AUDIENCE: So I noticed in the
video at the very end that the
young patient was saying that in
the hospital my doctor told
me I should come here, which
sounds like the old fashioned
way of getting information
out.
Ideally patients who need your
technology should know exactly
what's available.
So what are your thoughts about
how you're going to make
sure that people who need knees
know what they can have?
KRISTA DONALDSON: That's
a great question.
And I'd love Vin to
address this, too.
I mean one of the challenges,
again if you go back to our
goal of re-mobilization, a lot
of the amputees just don't
know that the product
is available.
And we don't, other than working
with patients to
understand the fitting and
what they go through, our
partner who really interfaces
is the Jaipur Foot
Organization.
And we know that they do media
campaigns, and will drive into
communities, and they
do these camps.
But that's actually
a huge problem.
And one of the things that we're
dealing with now with
Brilliance is actually SEOs
because we know we have target
countries that really
need this product.
If they type in photo therapy
device, we want them to see
Brilliance, because
we know that the
price point is perfect.
So this is part of what we're
really learning, I would say,
with the delivery phase.
Do you want to add
anything to that?
Because I think this is a
big issue with amputees.
VIN NARAYAN: Yeah.
And we're seeing that there
are limitations to scaling
both on the supply
and demand side.
So on the supply side, it's
all the typical problems.
There are not enough clinics.
They don't have access
to what they need.
On the demand side, it's a lot
of times people just don't
know what's available.
And we're hoping that that
problem is reducing.
We're seeing a lot of clinics
approaching it with some
innovative techniques.
So some clinics do radio
broadcast when they're going
to a new area.
Or some people are putting
out web hits.
And we're starting to get more
and more inquiries from people
in country just from
the information
we have on the web.
We don't know if that's just
because we're only reaching
the web savvy clinics.
And maybe there's this whole
other suite that isn't.
But we see a really good tactic
in taking what works
best in some areas and trying to
spread those best practices
to other clinics so that they're
able to get the word
out better as well.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Let's just give
them a round of applause.
KRISTA DONALDSON: Thank you.